lutte contre l'islam radical ou dérives
xénophobes
le texte sur l'interdiction de se
dissimuler le visage en public a été
acceptée hier par les électeurs suisses
à 51,21 % des voix l'initiative portée
par le parti populiste udc n'évoque ni
la burqa ni le niqab mais vise
directement les femmes musulmanes
portant le voile intégral
le résultat est à l'image de la division
des partis politiques suisses sur le
sujet les partisans du texte salue un
signal fort contre l'islam radical
ses opposants dénoncent une initiative
sexistes et xénophobe être libre c'est
pouvoir montrer son visage respecter la
dignité de la femme avoir une identité
et donc je ne comprends pas
l'argumentation des personnes qui
veulent emprisonner des femmes derrière
ce voile on a voté pour un taxi concerne
une trentaine de femmes donc c'est
vraiment un usage démagogique
l'initiative de ce droit d'initiative
populaire
et c'est dans ce sens là que l'on le
dénonce vraiment cet usage démagogique
et puis cette volonté de stratégie une
communauté qui est extrêmement bien
intégrés chez nous en suisse
et si la classe politique partagée la
population suisse l'est tout autant et
d'autres gels et je ne pense pas que ça
va vraiment comment dire que ça va
vraiment dissipé la menace terroriste
mais c'est surtout quelque chose de
symbolique à long terme est ce que ce
sera une bonne chose ou non je ne peux
pas le dire
90e a qu'un bus n
[Musique]
c'est ma liberté je ne voudrais pas que
quelqu'un me force à enlever mon voile
ou à lemaitre d'une certaine manière
finalement ce n'est pas très différente
de porter un masque ou pas je pense que
chacun devrait décider chacun doit
pouvoir choisir s'il couvre son visage
ou non ça ne devrait pas être contrôlée
par la loi en 2009 les suisses avaient
déjà voté l'interdiction de la
construction de minarets sur les
mosquées selon les chiffres de l'office
des statistiques suisses datant de 2010
9 environ 5 25% de la population est
musulmane soit un peu plus de quatre
cent mille personnes